back to the
fundamental nature of space time let me
ask you because
we're kind of left at i'd like to go
back to this idea of
that you said that everything we think
say or do occurs within the bounds of
space-time
so first of all maybe you can comment on
what do you mean in this context about
space
time but also about the nature of
uh truth like how much of all this is
noble
how much of this is accessible to us
humans how much
uncertainty like we're talking about is
there in the world
uh are you do you fall in a place where
we can
reason deeply about this world and it's
noble or
is it mostly chaos and we're just
holding on for dear life
yeah i think i said that all action
occurs within the bounds of space time
the other thing
everything we say do we make the other
thing is that everything we say do or
make starts out as an idea
so there's this concept of universal
darwinism which basically
um applies darwinian principles
but outside of the biological sphere so
we could say that this kind of gets into
richard dawkins mimetics that even ideas
are competing
reproducing recombining uh that idea is
so powerful by the way i i don't think
it's been understood
fully uh i think in the digital
in uh in the 21st century in the digital
world from my perspective in artificial
intelligence
there's yet to be some profound things
to be discovered about this whole
contract
agreed completely it's been called
an acid actually and that it just it
strips away
all of the non-informational components
of something that strips it down to its
bare bones
um i have a quote in here somewhere
about that but
yeah sorry which is called an asset the
idea ideas the universal darwinism
darwin is implied broadly outside of
this broadly
and um i would all condition all of this
with saying that a lot
most of my thinking is shaped by a book
i read recently called the case against
reality
um which introduced me to this concept
but it tied into
darwinism that i've used more broadly in
the past looking at things like money
and economics
so the book the case against reality by
donald hoffman
he has a quote in the book that
describes
universal darwinism it says quote
universal darwinism can
without risk of refuting itself address
our key question
does natural selection favor true
perceptions
if the answer happens to be no then it
hasn't shot itself in the foot
the uncanny power of universal darwinism
has been likened by the philosopher
dan dennett to a universal acid
and dendinet says quote there is no
denying at this point
that darwin's idea is a universal
solvent capable of cutting right to the
heart of everything in sight
the question is what does it leave
behind i have tried to show that once it
passes through everything we are left
with stronger
sounder versions of our most important
ideas
some of the traditional details perish
and some of these are losses to be
regretted
but good riddance to the rest of them
what remains is more than enough to
build on
unquote so the way i would
interpret that is that life itself
i've come to view life as information
propagating through flesh
and that we are i guess
dna is a quadratic code i think it's
four letters maybe versus a binary zeros
and ones
and we are ideas we are strategies
competing with each other
and nature is that which selects
it's what selects the winning ideas the
ones that are most fit
um to to environmental conditions
frankly
you know talking about sovereignty and
individualism
there might need to be some rethinking
here about what is
actually the basic individual entity
that is to be sovereign
like maybe our biological meat
vehicles were like way overly attached
to them
like maybe uh especially with genetics
and all those kinds of things or
artificial intelligence or living more
and more in virtual worlds
will become detached from that kind of
idea
so for example if i can clone you you
know
make make one million robbers
and you know but you'll all have the
same idea
what is real your real value as the like
i could just shoot you and they'll still
be
999 of you but the idea is the important
thing
yeah the the things you believe so
i would argue that i don't know even if
you clone someone perfectly i don't
think you can reproduce
the individual themselves because
they're we're all
a product of nature and nurture right so
my particular
con course of experiences the path
dependence that i represent
cannot be replicated as nor can anyone's
for that matter
well that's that's a hypothesis so we
that's of course a human
meat bag would say so
[Laughter]
like desperately trying to preserve
himself uh you know it's
i think it reduces to some fundamental
questions about what is consciousness
and whether that can be cloned
all those kind you know it gets the core
of what it is to be human
what uh what are the things that make
you particularly you
yeah i think it would assume kind of a
materialist viewpoint on reality and
that if you could reproduce
every atom of an individual that you
would have their experience encapsulated
in that
and you know hoffman's which is the book
is very radical
he argues that space and time is not an
objective reality
it's a biological interface so we
are scanning our environment for fitness
payoffs
and this space and time is the rendering
specific to human beings that allows us
to navigate reality
effectively so the further argument
would be that we all have
pretty similar interfaces but they're
all slightly different too
because we're all you know adapting in
different ways and that different
animals have their own
unique interfaces so we have a certain
amount of photoreceptors in our eye
whereas i think the number's three might
be five
or something like the mantis shrimp has
like seven or nine
so they can see and we only see
one ten trillionth of the light spectrum
so talk about a tiny fraction i mean 1
10 trillionth is a
very minuscule number and that makes up
all of the light that we can interpret
with our eyes
but something like a mantis shrimp could
see you know much more of that
so i think there's this
we're very conditioned to have a fully
materialist viewpoint on reality today
where we think uh you know the atomic
clockwork kind of universe
but i think there's i don't think that's
true exactly
and another school that goes into that
is actually austrian economics
where we could say that you know we
mentioned earlier that
an asset is not property it's actually
based on the relationship between the
individual and the property
there's this whole realm of relevance
associated with uh
we're all moving through life in the
course of a goal-directed action
so when we walk across a room i go from
a to b
it's because i valued b more than a so
value is inseparable from human action
we have a rank ordered value system in
our mind each of us
and we're constantly taking action in
accordance with those rank values
anything that accelerates us on the
course
of our goal directed action towards our
goal is
useful anything that impedes us
or we can say is valuable anything that
impedes us is actually
obstructing to value and anything that's
irrelevant is just valueless
so this table
that we're using right now like this is
a it's an accessory to you and i
because it's holding this paper that's
holding the information that's guiding
our conversation
but we could pay some 100 to jump over
this table
and this table could simultaneously be
an accessory to you and i and an
obstacle to someone else
so it's this domain this silent
contention of willpower and agendas
occurring across the face of the earth
that um is what austrian economics
really looks at
it's the the realm of human action as
they call it's called praxeology
so it's a non-materialist viewpoint on
reality in that
things we think in terms of matter
being reality but it's often more so in
the sphere of human action
what matters that is reality it's the
relevance of a thing
to the course of one's goal-directed
action and that's ultimately i
exist in the space of ideas yes not in
the space of physical matter
and just to jump back to this line here
i think his fundamental line here is
the question is talking about universal
darwinism as an acid what does it leave
behind
i've tried to show that once it passes
through everything we're left with
stronger
sounder versions of our most useful
ideas
that's the key point to me and that
ideas and information
so far as we can tell are the most
fundamental substrate
of reality and information itself
back to entropy information is the
resolution of entropy
that's what the bit is right it's a one
or zero whatever reduces your entropy by
half is a bit
and we measure information in bets so
and you're right people don't have ideas
ideas have people
i mean honestly i mean it's it's a
really profound idea
uh or uh a statement about reality
a reframing of reality it's uh if we're
actually being
deeply honest about it it's quite
painful i
i do appreciate that you defended your
biological meat bag earlier
but it seems like ideas are the things
that have power
that uh me lex for example is
worthless and
relative to the ideas that used my brain
for a bit of a time but so far as we
know
only human beings can generate and share
ideas so you can't say lex is worthless
like you are the node of the idea sphere
the newest fear so i'm i'm uh i'm what
is it uh from a bitcoin perspective i'm
like i'm mining
i'm solving the cryptographic problem
and uh
generation uh i'm i'm a use in that
sense i'm a useful node
uh yeah you're competing to solve the
the puzzle of entropy right and when you
do solve it it benefits the entire
network
you